est-ce que vous vous souvenez de ce qui
vous a fait abandonner la croyance au
Père Noël c'est la fin de l'année on
attaque donc le désormais traditionnel
épisode de Noël après avoir retracé avec
levistros les origines mythiques de Noël
qu'il analyse en bon anthropologue dans
les dimensions rituelles et initiatique
nous avions exploré l'année dernière une
vision plus fonctionnaliste de la
tradition avec Marcel MOS en montrant
que le Père Noël permet principalement
d'atténuer la violence du don en
exemptant les jeunes enfants d'offrir un
contreddon à une entité qui est
présentée comme magie
cette année on va donc s'intéresser à la
croyance au Père Noël et plus
spécifiquement à son abandon d'un point
de vue rationaliste avec le sociologue
spécialiste des croyances Gérald Brunner
et du chapitre qu'il consacre au Père
Noël dans son livre de 2005 vie et mort
des croyances collectives ce livre là on
y
[Musique]
va pour commencer Bronner se place dans
le cadre de pensée de Raymond Boudon qui
est le chef de fil de l'individualisme
méthodologique pour faire simple Boudon
s'oppose assez fortement à des
chercheurs qu'on pourrait qualifier de
structuralistes comme Bourdieu ou
lesvistros pour lesquels le sens des
actions individuelles sont souvent à
chercher dans les structures sociales
par exemple ici les visistros faisait
clairement l'hypothèse que le sens
profond d'un mythe comme celui du Père
Noël échappe largement aux acteurs
sociaux et qu'il est porteur d'une
densité historique et symbolique dont on
n'a pas forcément conscience Boudon lui
il va éviter complètement cette échelle
d'analyse he pour montrer que les
actions individuelles s'expliquent le
plus souvent par la rationalité des
acteurs en clair si quelqu'un fait ou
croit à quelque chose c'est qu'il a de
bonnes raisons de le faire ou d'y croire
alors attention il faut quand même noter
que quand Boudon parle de bonne raison
il ne parle pas du tout de raison vraie
par exemple il peut être parfaitement
rationnel de penser que le soleil tourne
autour de la terre si on est un Français
moyen du 15e siècle tout comme on peut
penser que no way home est le meilleur
film Spider-Man si on a 12 ans et demi
et qu'on a vu que H films dans toute sa
vie alors attention c'est la fin de
l'année sa balance sec Bronner étudie
donc les bonnes raisons qu'ont les
enfants de croire au Père Noël il se
base sur 142 entretiens semi-directifs
réalisés pour moitié avec des enfants de
10 à 12 ans et pour moitié avec des
adultes de 25 à 30 ans évidemment il ne
s'agit que de personnes qui ne croient
plus au Père Noël hein puisque le but
c'est d'étudier la sortie de la croyance
et Bronner souig qu'à la base ils ont
fait 174 entretiens mais ils n'en on
retenu que 142 parce que bah un certain
nombre d'interviewés ne se rappelent pas
de ce qui avait fait qu'ils avaient
abandonné leurs croyances on touche
d'ailleurs là à une des limites un peu
inévitables de ce type d'étude he c'est
que on se base sur une reconstruction
puisqu'on fait appel aux souvenirs des
enquêés qui par définition ne sont pas
toujours fiables d'ailleurs pour ma part
je ferai clairement partie des
entretiens abandonnés car je ne me
souviens pas du tout de ce qui m'a fait
cesser de croire au Père Noël il me
semble vaguement que ma sœur ou des
enfants plus âgés me l'avaient dit mais
je me souviens pas du tout du moment où
j'ai fait la bascule cognitive
d'ailleurs ça m'intéresse dites-moi dans
les commentaires si vous vous souvenez
de pourquoi vous avez arrêté de croire
au Père Noël et quelle était la raison
si vous vous en souvenez malgré les
limites on peut raisonnablement penser
que les résultats ne sont quand même pas
trop biaisés et c'est notamment parce
qu'on observe assez peu de différence
entre les deux classe d'âge alors que il
y en a clairement une qui fait appel à
des souvenirs beaucoup plus récents pour
le groupe des 10 12 ans ils ont on
abandonné la croyance depuis seulement
quelques années voire quelques mois on
observe d'ailleurs pas de différence
dans l'âge de la fin de la croyance
entre les deux groupes qui est de 6,96
ans pour les 10 12 ans et de 7,02 ans
pour les 25 300 ans donc on est très
très proche alors qu'on aurait pu
s'attendre à ce que les 10 12 ans
minimisent un petit peu parce que il
peut être un petit peu dévalorisant pour
les enfants de cet âge-là d'admettre
d'avoir cru tardivement au Père Noël
mais non on ne voit pas du tout ça dans
l'enquête alors avant d'étudier la fin
de la croyance il est important de noter
que la croyance au Père Noël peut
s'étudier comme une croyance tout à fait
rationnelle et fondée sur des preuves à
l'heure où j'enregistre mandax de la
chaîne la tranche ombier vient de sortir
une vidéo sur le Père Noël dans laquelle
il détaille justement à quel point il
serait de mauvaise foi de notre part de
taxer de crédule les enfants qui croient
au Père Noël parce qu'ils sont justement
parfaitement rationnellement fondés à
adhérer à cette croyance compte tenu de
leur environnement Brunner soulligne
donc les nombreuses bonnes raisons de
croire au per Noël les principales étant
l'autorité morale des parents le
caractère communément partagé de la
croyance dans toutes les sphères
sociales et surtout l'existence de
preuves matérielles de fait l'existence
du Père Noël permet déjà d'expliquer
l'origine des cadeaux et selon les
familles on peut aussi trouver des
traces dans la neige des cookies à
moitié grignoté ou des réponses
manuscrites aux lettres adressées au
vieux barbu et en plus de tout ça
Bronner soulligne que l'hypothèse le
Père Noël existe jouit de deux avantages
considérables surtout pour les enfants
plus jeunes d'abord elle est
infalsifiable c'est-à-dire que les
enfants ne peuvent pas prouver qu'elle
est fausse souvent parce qu'ils dorment
pendant le passage du Père Noël et
ensuite parce qu'elle a ce que Bronner
appelle un monopole cognitif
c'est-à-dire que pendant bien longtemps
il n'existe tout simplement aucune
hypothèse concurrente qui pourrait venir
faire de l'ombre à la croyance et on
verra justement que l'intrusion d'une
hypothèse concurrente sera souvent à la
racine du processus de décroy
je sais pas si ça se dit vraiment des
croyances enfin Bronner soulligne aussi
un versant plus utilitariste qui
pourrait permettre d'expliquer la
croyance un certain nombre d'enquêé
racontent avoir entretenu la croyance au
Père Noël par crainte de ne plus
recevoir de cadeaux s'il cessait d'y
croire quelle bande de petits
utilitaristes calculateurs mais
penchons-nous à présent sur les fameux
abandons de croyance alors déjà une
chose importante à Notter c'est que la
fin de la croyance au Père Noël peut
provoquer une crise et c'est le cas dans
45,5 % des cas et quand je parle de
crise he ça peut se muer en violence
souvent sous la forme d'insulte de BAFF
ou d'un goûter à peine entamé jeté au
visage du révélateur de vérité et ça
provoque aussi une profonde et
douloureuse remise en question de la
vision du monde de l'enfant he qui dans
certains cas les a amené à percevoir
l'entièreté du monde des adultes avec
suspicion et à remettre en cause toutes
sortes de croyances comme notamment la
croyance en Dieu il est aussi important
de rassurer les enfants parce que parmi
ceux qui affirment ne pas avoir été
déçus la plupart S que c'est parce qu'il
savait qu'il continueraiit à recevoir
des cadeaux et on n'oublie pas non plus
he la dimension rituelle parce que
beaucoup d'entre eux évoquent
l'impression agréable d'entrer dans la
cour des grands d'ailleurs en général
les enfants sont assez contents de faire
perdurer le mythe auprès des petits
frères et petites sœurs et de se mettre
ainsi du côté des adultes mais ça on
avait déjà parlé dans la vidéo sur les
vistros par ailleurs la soudaineté de la
rupture est une dimension importante
parce qu'on remarque que les ruptures
soudaines entraînent des crises dans
59,2 % des cas alors que les ruptures
plus progressive dans seulement 27,5 %
des cas comme l'écrit Bronner ceci
suggère qu'une rupture progressive de la
croyance permet à l'individu de préparer
son système cognitif à subir un assaut
et éventuellement de désinvestir
émotionnellement une place montrant des
signes de faiblesse moralité ne soyez
pas des connards cyniques en voulant à
tout prix révéler la vérité aux enfants
pour leur propre bien la rupture de
croyance brutale c'est probablement pas
le plus bienveillant après ça Bronner
parvient finalement assez bien à montrer
en quoi la croyance au Père Noël peut
s'analyser sous l'angle de la
rationalité subjective en faisant une
typologie de la rupture de la croyance
qui se fait selon trois modalités la
dissonance la concurrence et
l'incohérence alors le premier élément
et le plus souvent évoqué est la
dissonance elle fait appel à la notion
désormais célèbre de dissonance
cognitive développée par Festinger dans
l'échec d'une prophétie j'en parle
notamment dans mon livre si vous voulez
creuser l'idée de la dis ici c'est quand
un élément externe à la croyance vient
contredire affaiblir ou réduire la
crédibilité du mythe le plus souvent
hein cette dissonance porte sur
l'identité du père Noël l'identité des
donateurs ou sur les cadeaux eux-mêmes
pour le premier cas hein c'est par
exemple quand on reconnaît la voix ou
laaleine de son oncle quand on voit le
Père Noël pour l'identité des donateurs
ça peut être parce que les copains de
classe nous ont dit que bah ce sont les
parents qui font les cadeaux ou parce
qu'on surprend les parents au milieu de
la nuit et dans le cas des cadeau c'est
plutôt une sorte de dissonance
temporelle c'est lorsque les enfants
tombent par hasard sur les cadeaux avant
la date de Noël he par exemple caché
dans une armoire ou au grenier et qu'il
les reçoiv ensuite le jour J là il
commence à se dire que il y a quelque
chose qui va pas certains poussent même
le raisonnement jusqu'à aller vérifier
la cachette le lendemain de Noël pour
s'assurer de la disparition des cadeaux
avant de tirer leur conclusions c'est
dire s'ils ont un raisonnement pour le
coup rationnel il y a bien sûr plein
d'autres dissonances possibles comme la
multiplicité des Pères Noël surtout
quand on habite en ville ou tout ce qui
tourne autour des problèmes de cheminée
on a aussi une catégorie Divers avec
toutes les situations assez rares he
comme ces deux intervenants qui
déclarent avoir abandonné leurs croyance
en regardant le film Le Père Noël est
une ordure pas possible ce matin encore
on était dans les bras dans l'autre à
rououler comme deux pigeons qui sèent
Laour temps FX Noël
F pour le cas concurrence c'est lorsque
la thèse le Père Noël existe n'a plus le
monopole indiscuté mais que d'autres
thèses concurrentes peuvent faire leur
apparition comme ce sont les parents qui
offrent les cadeaux ou encore c'est la
main invisible des marchés qui permet le
bien-être collectif oui je sais ça n'a
rien à voir mais ça qualifie d'hypothèse
concurrente bref pour qu'émerge une
thèse concurrente les autres sont bien
sûr très importants et on s'aperçoit que
dans la moitié des cas il s'agit de
camarades suivi de près par les parents
puis les frères et sœurs évidemment on
sera d'autant plus disposé à accepter
une thèse concurrente quand elle vient
de personne à qui on accorde du crédit
c'est évidemment le cas des parents hein
mais au sein de la cour d'école les
enfants s'aperçoivent bien vite en
comparant le camp des croyants et celui
des non croyants que ce dernier est bien
davantage composé d'élèves plus vieux ce
qui donne évidemment du poids et un
certain prestige à leurs paroes enfin la
dernière typologie de rupture est celle
de l'incohérence qui survient lorsqu'un
alément interne au mythe est remise en
question Brunner les regroupe donc en
trois catégories et confirme un trait
que j'avais déjà noté chez lui il est
nul en
non mais j'avais déjà vu chez lui des
graphiques sans légende ou sans échelle
et qui donc n'apportent pas grand-chose
au texte et là on a pas de légende donc
on est un peu dans cette situation là on
peut pas comprendre le graphique sur le
texte bref avec les sous-titres on a
donc 62 % des incohérences qui
concernent les éléments fantastiques qui
commencent à devenir un peu
invraisemblable comme l'omniscience du
Père Noël les lutins les rennes tout ça
29 % des témoignages concernent les
impossibilités physiques comme la taille
de la cheminée ou la possibilité
temporelle de livrer le monde entier en
une seule nuit et enfin les 9 % restants
concernent le fait que le Père Noël
puisse habiter au pôle nord ou au centre
de la Terre he suivant les
versions ce qui semble évidemment
improbable et à fororie d'y avoir une
usine à jouet il faut bien noter que le
plus souvent on assiste à une
combinaison de ces différentes ruptures
le plus fréquent reste la rupture par
dissonance rapidement suivi par le combo
dissonance plus concurrence suivi par la
concurrence seule pour conclure on peut
donc dire avec Bronner que les enfants
ont bien de bonnes raisons de croire au
Père Noël et qu'il s'appuie pour cela
sur des éléments concrets et rationnels
qui sont justement remis en cause au
moment de l'abandon de la croyance
évidemment ce serait intéressant de
pouvoir généraliser cet exemple à la
façon dont on adhère ou dont on se
défait d'autres croyances mais ça peut
être assez difficile he d'avoir des
données statistiques sur des sorties de
croyances mystiques ou religieuses alors
que là quasi totalité de la population
est passé par l'adhésion plus l'abandon
de la croyance au Père Noël ce qui en
fait naturellement un terrain d'étude
privilégié si vous souhaitez aller plus
loin vous pouvez bien sûr lire le
chapitre 4 du livre vie et mort des
croyances collectives mais je vous
mettrai aussi en description la première
version de cette étude qui était un
article publié en 2004 dans la revue
cahier internationaux de sociologie et
qui a la bonne idée d'être en libre
accès c'est tout pour aujourd'hui je
vous souhaite une excellente fin d'année
2023 et j'espère trouver plus de temps
pour faire des vidéos en 2024 je vous
fais des gros bisous et à très vite
[Musique]
Ciao